Je vis dans une ville construite ici J'ai besoin d'un
bougre effronté c'était un endroit fou quand
ce chien est arrivé du Devon préparez-vous à
devenir sauvage il était comme un chien pour tout le monde
bon garçon deuxième un pieux pour tous mais personne
jusqu'à ce qu'il rencontre ces deux  les maîtres chiens dans
le
bus depuis qu'il est devenu membre du syndicat
toujours à l'intérieur à l'extérieur nous pensons qu'elle a
raison sur les visages tristes du
monde ne fonctionnera pas donc vous pouvez simplement vous arrêter
parfois vous chien pointilleux
parfois votre chien vous choisit de monter à
bord
personne ne s'assoit  là quand les morts sont assis il y a
maintenant un gentleman et quelqu'un
comprend le sien mais l'importance du
coeur généreux